so what we face in our culture our great
trial is temptation that's our that's
our battle and of course every Christian
across the world has to deal across
history has to deal with temptation of
one kind or another but not every
Christian has lived or does live as we
do now in a in a world in a culture I
should say seemingly designed with no
other purpose than to tempt so we're
surrounded on all sides by this
temptation every time we go on our
phones every time we go online you know
you scroll down a newsfeed every time
you turn on the TV every time you walk
outside of your home every time you
enter into conversation with another
person out in the world every time we do
anything or go anywhere
we're subject to this intense relentless
constant temptation which is why you
know I'll sometimes hear Christians say
that well you know we we've got it easy
here in this country in comparison to
Christians overseas or persecuted
we're the ones who got the we got the
easy end of the of the bargain
which is true physically we have
physically we've got it a lot easier and
that's definitely true spiritually we
really don't which is why I would wager
that
in the end when when if we're if we're
you know taking if we're taking account
here if we're if we're counting heads I
think in the end they're gonna be far
more Christians from the Middle East who
suffered persecution far more of them
are going to be in heaven than
Christians here
because our culture this atmosphere is
so effective at drawing Christians
luring them into a life of materialism
hedonism nihilism our entire culture is
kind of a current running away from
Christ so even if you don't go out of
your way to indulge every vice like our
culture wants you to do but even if you
know
still you could be swept up and kind of
swept away ultimately into hell if you
just try to sort of exist
get along without making any considered
effort to actually be a Christian if you
don't actually practice self-denial if
you don't practice obedience if you're
not always walking towards God and
making that that effort to do so
swimming against the stream
if you don't then the force of
everything will just cause you to drift
in the opposite direction
so what I'm saying is that the greatest
temptation in our culture isn't anyone
temptation or another although they're
all
serious but the greatest temptation
temptation is simply the temptation not
to worry much about temptation not to
worry much about being a Christian not
to worry much about denying yourself and
to just kind of go with the flow
that's the number-one temptation for us
is to go with the flow and it's a very
potent very tempting temptation and one
that I believe has claimed that many
many many souls
um
I think there are many souls in hell who
on the outside if we were just viewing
their life if we could just kind of
rewind the tape and look back at
everything they did we wouldn't find
many instances of them doing something
that seems from the outside especially
horrible
what we would see instead is just a
whole lot a little justjust just a life
that was consumed by these quote little
sins and they just kind of went with
and just sort of floated and just
existed going with the flow just going
wherever the culture goes
the culture says well this is okay than
they did that thing you know whatever it
is what everyone else is doing they did
it
but they weren't it's not like they were
out killing people it's not like they
were rapists child molesters you know
we're not talking about that
but just people who you know whatever
everyone thinks is fine they just
they're you know they'll do that
you
III think he'll is probably primarily
populated with those kinds of people so
I think it may be worthwhile to
to understand what exactly temptation is
and how we handle it and for this as
always of course we can turn to
Scripture and there's
the story in Scripture that I've been
thinking a lot about recently is the
story of G of Christ's temptation in the
desert
we're told that at the beginning of his
public ministry right after he was
baptized Jesus went out to the desert he
was led to the desert we were told in
order to undergo this trial he in order
to be tempted by Satan he went to the
desert to be tempted by Satan and so it
seems kind of like he was going to the
desert and sort of calling calling Satan
out he was saying okay Satan come and do
your worst now now's your chance yeah
and and he went into the he went into
this duel with Satan with one hand tied
behind his back metaphorically because
he starved himself for forty days first
and then he said alright Satan
Here I am
now why did he do this I've been
thinking a lot about that question what
was the point
of this whole scene
I I think there are a couple of reasons
for that probably probably more than a
couple but here the couple that I can
that in my in my little meager mind I
can see
first we know that Christ was fully man
and fully God and if he was if he was
gonna be fully man then he had then he
was gonna share entirely in the human
experience he was going to drink from
the cup of human experience completely
and so he did and in a big part of the
human experience especially for us but
for all people his temptation so he went
to be tempted but Christ was the like
man in every way except sin so Christ
had no spiritual weaknesses so he
couldn't experience temptation exactly
the way that we experience it when you
and I are tempted tempted the devil is
not coming up to us physically in person
and saying hey why don't you do this
right that's not how we get tempted
because we're spiritually weak and frail
so evil can kind of we have these sort
of cracks in our soul that evil can
enter into and speak to us within
ourselves and entice us so when we're
tempted to do something it you know for
if we're saying oh I was tempted to do
XYZ it means that there's a real part of
you that really wants to do that thing
and is enticed by it and so you're
arguing with yourself should I do it or
should I not right and you've got that
internal dialogue going on but there's
definitely this significant force within
you that is telling you yes do it and
you really want to do it that's what
that's how the temptation works for for
mere mortals like us
but for Christ he doesn't have those
cracks in soul so when he was being
tempted by the devil there was never any
part of him that said to himself oh yeah
maybe I should do that you know there
was never a part of him that said yeah
maybe I should worship the devil maybe
hmm let me think and I think this is
this is something Christians I got into
an argument actually with a group of
Christians recently about this and they
insisted that no he was really human so
that means that he really you know he
was tempted just like we are
okay so you mean you're telling me that
you think Christ that God incarnate that
there was a part of him that actually
wanted to do to worship the devil that's
what you think no because that part of
you that wants to do sinful things
that is a result of sin
Christ has knows but he can be tempted
externally which means that the
temptation can sort of walk up to him
not get inside him but walk up to him
and speak to him and he allowed that
anyway so I think that was one part of
the reason but the second part is that
he was exposing I think he was exposing
Satan he was kind of drawing the snake
out from under the rock
so that we could see him and understand
him and see how evil functions
I think that's that's that's the the
main thing we could take away from this
store it's very important story
that Jesus is showing us
seyton
showing us this is what how temptation
works
so Satan thought that he was going to
get the best of of God
but really it was the other way around
and he was exposed and now and we all
learned quite a lot about him from this
exchange and what do we learn well first
we learned that that
seyton evil is prideful to the point of
insanity let me think about it the devil
was trying to tempt God
how crazy is that he must have known
that that it wasn't gonna work that
there was no way you must have known on
some level
given that he knows who God is and he
understands God far more than any of us
do
um
so he must have known
but there was no way this was gonna work
he was only gonna be humiliated in the
end but he tried anyway and that's pride
because Satan is just pride and we do
the same thing don't we you know in our
in our pride we try to win these little
sort of victories over God God tells us
to reject sin to live holy virtuous
lives God tells us that that's the only
way we're gonna be happy and where they
were gonna have a joyful lives yeah we
go looking for joy elsewhere
we know that God's tell if we believe
that means that we know God's telling
the truth we know that it's true we know
that sin can lead to only death and
misery
yeah we do it anyway we try to kind of
game the system
we want to see if we could have it both
ways we want to see if what can we have
the joy and can we have the sin as well
knowing so on one level we're doing that
but on another level we know that it's
not going to work yet we do it
um we go looking for joy where it cannot
be we look for joy within our favorite
sins knowing intellectually that they
that these sins will bring us only
misery
of us that thinks well maybe we can have
it all maybe we can have everything
right we can have the joy of this sin
and the joy of eternal life
and that's just pride we are humiliating
ourselves the way that Satan humiliated
himself
and so Jesus drew evil out into the open
in full view
so that we could recognize it within
ourselves so that we can look into those
cracks in the soul to see okay that's
what's going on there
I think the next thing that we learned
which is a very scary thing is that
Satan is a theologian
Pope Benedict wrote a book called the
Jesus of Nazareth which is a great book
recommend for everybody and he makes
this point he says Satan Satan is a
theologian
he knows scripture backwards and
forwards
and so he uses God's own book against
him he gets into this theological debate
with God
because he knows the book and he knows
it better than we do
attempts him Christ quotes the quote
scripture Adam and then what is Satan -
he throws a right back at him
which again is pride but it also shows
well he knows he knows the Bible
and that tells us that first of all
knowledge of the Bible does not in
itself mean that a person is saved
just as believing that Jesus is the Son
of God believing that he's the Messiah
that's not gonna save you either because
gee because Satan knows both of those
things
he doesn't just believe them he knows
them
Satan knows the Bible he could recite it
you can recite the entire thing could
you cuz I can't
and Satan knows for certain that Jesus
is the Son of God is the Messiah
um yeah it's aton is still safe
Satan's flaw is not that he believes the
wrong thing it's not that he doesn't
know the Bible enough it's not that he
doesn't know who God is he's confused
it's not that he's an atheist and he's
rejecting he pretends that God doesn't
exist okay if he was gonna pretend a
Jesus didn't exist then he wouldn't have
been this whole scene in the desert
never would have happened
that's not it at all his is his great
flaw his great sin that got him cast out
of heaven is that he does not love God
and he will not serve Him it's got
nothing at all to do with belief or
knowing the Bible or anything like that
it's just I will not serve
that's what Satan said I will not sir
so next we learn and this is very
important I think next we learn the
forms of temptation
that will be used against us
and this is this is what makes it so
this is the brita this is Christ's
brilliance
is is that he is showing us essentially
the three great forms of temptation
where he's not showing us Satan is
showing us he's drawing Satan out and
then Satan will expose himself by
showing us not just you know who he is
but also the exact forms of temptation
he's going to use so Satan tempts Christ
first to turn rocks into bread
so that he can eat which is appealing to
his physical appetites then Satan tempts
Christ to throw himself off a cliff
and allow the angels to come save him in
some great you know some some great
demonstration of his heavenly power
and that's an appeal to pride and to ego
and that's a temptation that a lot that
you and I probably
we would be very tempted to actually go
through with that if we knew you know if
we if someone told us that you know what
you could you could you could jump off
of this building in front of everybody
and a great a great swarm of angels will
come and and and grab you out of the air
and place you back on the ground
well I'd be a very serious temptation
so that's pride and ego that's what he's
Satan is trying to appeal to
and then he tempts Christ to worship Him
the devil and in return he'll receive
all the power in the world and that's an
appeal to materialism so that we have it
we see here the cry that Satan seeks to
make of us gluttons egoist and
materialists and he'll settle for just
one
but of course nowadays he has little
trouble getting us to be all three if he
could just get us to be egotistical then
he would even then it doesn't matter if
we're you know we could doesn't matter
for materialistic or or or gluttonous
but these days what we you know it's
it's no problem we'll we'll be all those
things
and I think the final and really
important thing we learned
is how we can overcome these temptations
that really is the most important point
how do we
when the devil does come to us and says
hey why don't you do this and he's
whispering in our ear how do we overcome
it how do we deal with
well how does Christ deal with every
salvo from the devil he quotes Scripture
and that was for our benefit not his I
mean this was all for us
price could have easily said to the
devil get out of here but you know could
have swatted him away like a fly right
little twerp you're gonna see gonna
smack them halfway across the desert if
you want it to
I mean we have to understand that that's
Satan to create in comparison to Christ
is just like a just a little fly a
little net means nothing is just
nothingness
so Jesus could have done that could have
just ignored him
but he did
because that would not be a model that
we can follow
Christ can respond to that the devil
that way if he wants to we cannot
because we are no match Christ is a
match he's much more than a match for
the devil the devil's nothing in
comparison to him literally nothing in
comparison to him but we it's different
for us
we're no match for the devil we're no
match for this for the forces of hell
say Satan is smarter than us he's
stronger than us he's more powerful he
knows scripture more than we do he knows
our own religion better than we do so we
can't win an argument with him we can't
win a fight with him
or puny or weak
I mean he can stay focused a focused
when he's got a plan of action a plan of
attack for how he's gonna take you down
he'll stay focused on it your entire
life and he's never gonna waver from it
whereas you can't stay focused on
anything for more than two seconds right
you and I we're like these just
ridiculous little butterflies fluttering
around from one thing to the next we
can't we can't stay focused
Satan is staying focused on us so you
know we're outmatched
and Satan could eat us for breakfast
without a problem we can't be
we can't beat them on our own thatit's
and so I think what Christ is telling us
with his response is is we cannot rely
on our own understandings we can't rely
on our own strength we can't rely on our
own resilience and he's telling us to
just grasp on to God on to our faith to
use the Bible as our shield because he
can't harm us when we're huddled close
to the Lord
you can't
he can't grab us he can't take us when
we're walking with with Christ
because we can go where he cannot we can
flee into the arms of God we can stand
beneath the cross as our shelter Satan
can't
you
now what Christ is saying is listen when
the devil came for me
Scripture
I relied on the father and on and on
Scripture
that's what I did
so what do you think is going to happen
to you if you do not have those things
as a shield
if I had that shield what chance do you
have going up against the devil with
nothing unarmed you have no chance
you
and this is very important because we
live now in a desert of our own we live
in kind of a spiritual desert
and we really are alone out here you and
I
we can't look to the world to have our
back to support us to encourage us when
the devil comes for us
um
try to resist the devil to resist
temptation to try to live a pure and
holy life to attempt to be virtuous this
is only going to provoke laughter and
jeers from those around you including
other Christians they're just going to
mock you
and as satan grabs you by the ankles and
tries to drag you into hell and you
cling desperately to a to any kind of
rock or root that you can find
the world will come and start kind of
prying your fingers loose
stop resisting
it'll tell you
and it'll just sneer at you and spit on
you
it makes you feel stupid for even caring
you
this is the the situation that we face
that there's a war happening here
but it's a spiritual war and much of it
is invisible to us
and the tactic of the evil one
which is very different for the firm the
tactic that he uses in other parts of
the world but for us his tactic is to
just numb our souls and to fill our
stomachs and to rub our shoulders and to
pamper us
and to just give us everything our
hearts desire and even when we've had
everything there artists desire he'll
give us more so that our hearts will
develop new desires and these desires
become progressively more depraved and
disordered as we're just looking for
more things to want
and so the Devils very happy with us
just being comfortable
he's fine with that
that's what we should understand it the
devil doesn't want you to be
uncomfortable
Sarris he's good he doesn't want you to
just want to be uncomfortable he doesn't
want you to experience any pain or
anything right now right now
and he wants you to just indulge and to
be happy right now
and so that's why I think of course we
look to scripture and we look to the
example that we've been given
an example is we just have to cling
desperately to God and and that's our
only chance
but it's more than a chance of course if
we actually do that it's a if we
actually stay with God and cling to him
and stay in his light then
it is a certainty that we will be safe
the problem is that so few of us
actually do that
so just um couple reflections from
scripture for us today I'll leave it
there thanks for watching everybody god
speed
you